- What is the shadow docket
on the Supreme court?
Well, effectively there are
two different dockets or lists of
cases before the Supreme court.
There are the merits cases
on the merits docket,
where the court will
entertain extensive briefing.
The parties will come in
and have oral argument before the court,
and then they will issue a long opinion
agreeing with one party
and disagreeing with another party.
That's the normal
process, the merit stock.
And then there is the shadow docket,
which is largely made up of
cases that are asking for
emergency relief from the court.
They're saying that they can't
wait for a mayor's decision.
So they ask for an emergency
temporary restraining order
or an injunction from the Supreme court
often in these kinds of cases,
that emergency relief
is the whole ball game.
So if you're dismissing this thing
and not granting the emergency relief,
then there's no point in going forward
on a merit's decision.
As of the last four years,
the Supreme court has been
using the shadow docket to
dispose of cases without having
any precedential effect and
often with no opinion whatsoever,
no explanation of why they
held the way that they held.
And that's probably not good for anyone.